[Musique]
dans des laboratoires de grenoble une
équipe d'historiens 2 biomécanicien de
physiologiste et d'informaticiens
s'embarque pour une aventure à travers
le temps
[Musique]
mission pour la science est un aller
simple jusqu'à l'une des dates les plus
célèbres de l'histoire de france
15 sans qu'un un singe
[Musique]
il vous rejoindre l'armée de françois
1er pour traverser les halles envoûte
problème mythique bataille de marignan
marche dont nous ne connaissons que les
détails révélés par le roi dans une
lettre à sa mère
ces explorateurs temporel vont devoir se
mêler aux trous et tenter de mesurer
l'effort humain dont des armes ou de
plus de 40 kg
durant deux jours et vont guérir des
réponses grâce à l'archéologie
expérimentale
côtoyer des soldats du xvième siècle et
ne point languir pour atteindre 2641
mètres d'altitude
seront ils suffisamment hardi pour venir
à bout de leurs expériences